as well as the condolences of attorney
general bar and the entire department to
the family for this tragic loss this
morning I want to discuss the reasons
for our decision and how we reached it
while the department does not normally
publicly discuss a decision not to bring
charges we felt that this matter is an
exception because it means so much to
our community and beyond before I
continue let me say as clearly and
unequivocally as I can that mr. Gandhi's
death to the tragedy for anyone to die
under circumstances like these to be
tremendous loss for the family to suffer
at this family has for too long has only
compounded the loss with these
unassailable facts are separate and
distinct from whether a federal crime
has been committed and the evidence here
does not support charging police officer
Daniel Pantaleo or any other officer
with a federal criminal civil rights
violation admittedly many may disagree
with this decision and that is it right
however we hope that by announcing and
explaining our decision today we can
bring some measure of closure to one of
this city's more upsetting incidents
involving the police and a member of our
community to fully understand how we
made this decision I want to briefly
discuss the applicable law in order for
a federal criminal civil rights charge
to be brought the government must prove
beyond a reasonable
four elements first that the officer
acted under color of law second that the
officer used objectively unreasonable
force under the circumstances third that
the officer violate the law willfully
and forth that the wrongful conduct of
bodily injury to the victim in simpler
terms this means that the government
must prove beyond a reasonable doubt
that an officer willfully used more
force and he reasonably could have
believed was necessary under the
circumstances sure his department's
investigation we focus primarily on two
of these elements first whether the
force use was objectively unreasonable
under the circumstances and second
whether the officer acted willfully in
violation of the law the reasonableness
of a particular use of force must be
judged from the perspective of a
reasonable officer on the scene rather
than with 20/20 vision of hindsight and
the law recognizes that police are often
forced to make split-second judgment in
circumstances that are tense uncertain
and rapidly evolving however even if the
government can prove beyond a reasonable
doubt that the force used was
objectively unreasonable the government
must also prove beyond a reasonable
doubt that the officer acted willfully
this is the highest standard of intent
imposed by law and it is different and
higher than the intent standard on the
relevant state statutes
while willfulness willfulness may be
inferred from blatantly wrongful conduct
such as a gratuitous pic to the head
from officers mistake here misperception
or even poor judgment does not
constitute willful conduct under federal
criminal civil rights law what all of
this means is that even if we could
prove that officer Pantaleo spoilers a
mr. Gordon constituted unreasonable
force we would still have to prove
beyond a reasonable doubt that officer
Pantaleo acted willfully in violation of
law Eric Gardner's arrest was largely
captured on video and the video has been
replayed in the media on countless
occasions like many of you I watched
that video many times and each time I've
watched it I'm left with the same
reaction with the death of Eric Cartman
is a tragedy and I know that every one
of my colleagues who reviewed the video
share the same sentiment the job of a
federal prosecutor however is not to let
our emotions dictate our decisions our
job is to review the evidence gathered
during the investigation like the video
to assess whether we can prove that a
federal crime was committed when viewed
in its entirety the video documents a
tense and escalating encounter between
mr. Gardner and the officers it shows
that the officers had to make
split-second decisions under stressful
circumstances
the video shows that the officers
initial actions were in accordance to
the savage police tactics and procedures
but that the situation deteriorated has
it progressed at the end of the day
however the video and the other evidence
gathered in the investigation does not
establish beyond a reasonable doubt that
officer Pantaleo acted willfully in
violation of federal law now let me
address the video and some of the other
evidence on July 17 2014
officers Justin D'Amico and Daniel
Pantaleo attempted to place Eric Gardner
under arrest
the officers were acting that day under
direct orders to address complaints
about the sale of untaxed cigarettes in
the vicinity of Tompkinsville Park and
Staten Island mr. garner resisted arrest
both verbally and physically and
consequently the officers were permitted
to use force to affect the arrest that
force of course had to be reasonable
after mr. garner resisted arrest
officer Pantaleo appeared to attempt to
approved NYPD tactics both of which
involve the use of force first he
appeared to attempt an armbar which
involves pulling the hand of a person
down while the officer goes behind the
person to gain control of him to put
handcuffs on him as the video makes
clear mr. garner twisted his body and
free these arms evading panteleyev grasp
and avoided being placed in handcuffs
officer Pantaleo
next appeared to attempt a second crew
tactus tactic this one called the rear
takedown or seatbelt in this tactic an
officer places one arm under a person to
armpit and the other hand across the
shoulder and chest of the person in
order to unbalance the
and bring him to the ground here officer
Pantaleo placed his right arm under mr.
Gardiner's right armpit and his left arm
on mr. Gardner's shoulder and upper
chest with his left palm facing out and
away from mr. Gardner's neck at this
point there is nothing in the video to
suggest that officer Pantaleo intended
or attempted to place mr. Garner in a
chokehold I would also note that there
was a significant difference in size and
weight between mr. Gardner who stood 6
foot 2 and weighed close to 400 pounds
an officer Pantaleo who was considerably
smaller and it is clear that this
disparity and size and weight contribute
to officer Pantaleo being unable to
bring mr. Gardner under arrest quickly
and without further incident officer
Pantaleo then attempted to complete the
rear takedown to put mr. Gardner
off-balance this is where the situation
rapidly deteriorated as mr. Gardner and
officer Pantaleo struggled officer
Pantaleo held on to mr. garner and both
men fell backwards in the process
officer Pantaleo body slammed against a
store window causing the window to
buckle it appears that in response to
that collision and to maintain a hold on
mr. Gardner officer Pantaleo wrapped his
left arm around mr. Garner's neck
resulting in what was in effect a
chokehold officer Pantaleo maintained
that hold on mr. Gardner for a total of
approximately seven seconds during the
first few seconds of that hold the two
men were falling to the sidewalk
as has been widely reported mr. Gartner
stated I can't breathe but I would point
out that he made this statement only
after he fell to the sidewalk and after
officer Pantaleo released his grip from
mr. Gardner's neck
significantly officer Pantaleo was not
engaged in a chokehold on mr. garner
when he said he could not breathe a
neither officer Pantaleo nor any other
officer applied a chokehold to mr.
Gardner after he first said he could not
breathe I want to repeat that last
statement because it's very important to
the understanding and analysis of this
case officer Pantaleo was not engaged in
the chokehold on mr. Gardner when he
said he could not breathe and neither
officer Pantaleo nor any other officer
applied a chokehold to mr. Gardner after
he first said he could not breathe
he's also important to understand that
there is a disagreement among medical
experts regarding the cause of mr.
Garner's death while medical examiner we
conducted mr. Gardner's autopsy ruled it
a homicide meaning that the death
resulted rightly or wrongly from the
actions of another another medical
examiner reviewed the autopsy report
could not conclusively determine whether
the chokehold itself caused mr. Garner's
death at least two different medical
experts have explained that the sudden
cardiac arrest suffered by mr. Garber
could have resulted from a number of
causes in addition to the chokehold
including being restrained in a prone
position damage to his neck area that
was not attributable to the chokehold
and mr. Gardner serious underlying
medical conditions this is significant
because he cast doubt upon whether the
chokehold itself directly caused mr.
Gardner's death
when we evaluated officer Pantaleo
actions in light of his training and
experience mr. Garner's size weight and
actions to resist arrest and adoration
and escalating nature of the interaction
we determined that was insufficient
evidence to prove beyond a reasonable
doubt that Pantaleo acted in willful
violation of federal law as a result we
conclude that there is insufficient
evidence to bring a federal criminal
charge against officer Pantaleo for his
role in the untimely death of mr. Giorno
before I conclude I also would like to
address the timing of today's
announcement as I mentioned earlier this
investigation was extremely thorough and
time-consuming and a recent
administrative hearing conducted by the
NYPD provided at least potentially one
last opportunity to develop evidence
that might have put us in a position to
bring charges but regardless today's
announcement is long overdue we the
department owed it to mr. Gordon's
family and the community to complete the
investigation and announce our decision
earlier I should emphasize that this was
a very difficult decision and it was one
that was contemplated and considered at
the very highest levels of the
Department of Justice for several years
for the family for the community and for
the cause of justice please know that
experienced highly trained federal
agents and career prosecutors were part
to investigate and examine the facts to
determine if a federal criminal case
could be brought here
Department remains committed to
aggressively investigating allegations
of excessive force by police officers
and others and will continue to dedicate
all necessary resources to doing so we
are committed to aggressively
prosecuting excessive force cases
whenever there are sufficient evidence
to bring them mr. Garner's death was a
terrible tragedy that had me thoroughly
investigating the surrounding
circumstances the department has
concluded that the available evidence
would not support federal civil rights
charges against any officer we know and
understand that some will be
disappointed by this decision but it is
the conclusion that is compelled by the
evidence in the law thank you I know
that there will be questions that will
probbably more questions than we can
handle in this forum we will take a few
of them now and if there are subsequent
questions please direct them through our
Pio
and we'll do the best we can to answer
we certainly understand that view but as
federal prosecutors there are two things
that we have to be satisfied with before
we present a case to the grand jury that
is set forth in the justice manual which
guide key procedures and policies of the
department and has long done so first
it's federal prosecutors we must
actually be convinced beyond the reason
that we can present evidence beyond the
reasonable doubt that the defendant has
committed the crimes charged second we
must be convinced that there is
sufficient admissible evidence at trial
both the Gainey convicted and to sustain
it on appeal because in this case after
the full examination of the evidence we
have determined that we as the
prosecutors are not convinced that this
particularly defended a potential
defendant committed the offense we would
not go ahead and bring it to the grand
jury on the longest address the public
policy I'm saying it was a difficult to
say and that's in part why it took so
long
certainly there was a desire by many
people who worked on this case over many
years to do everything we could to
determine where charges could be brought
I would say that obviously the fact that
was on video made this different from
that some other cases where we don't
have that sort of compelling evidence
upfront but I'm not going to engage
whether it was closed from not closed
and just couldn't say that we put a lot
of time and effort into this there was a
lot of thoughtful discussion between the
courtroom and this is the conclusion
that is driven by the evidence in the
world
I did yes we did meet my leadership team
and on that with the Gordon family and
some of their advisers this morning it
wasn't completely it was very difficult
obviously and they were upset and they
had questions that we tried to answer I
will say is one of their advisers
pointed out in the meeting that the
family has consistently called for
peaceful protests in the in the spirit
of members of our society who have the
best interest of our city at heart and I
echo that we did our best to try to
explain why we reach the decision that
we reached but obviously to get the
discussion with the gardener family I
did express my condolences the
condolences of attorney general bar and
the department and I apologized for them
for how long this took because the delay
certainly is regrettable and
inappropriate
you should never have taken as long as
it did I don't think that the Blaine
anyway compromising investigations is
not a situation where evidence was lost
or memories faded people were
interviewed immediately after the
incident and more than four dozen
witnesses were interviewed law
enforcement civilian expert witnesses
and use of force medical examiner's and
others so I don't think that being lost
evidence by the delay but the delay is
entirely inappropriate and unacceptable
and as you said we've had a number of
changes US Attorney's I think there have
been probably five AG's who considered
this case certainly that was part of it
but I do think is a bill a due in part
to the fact that people want to be
absolutely certain that we look like
every factor in every aspect of this
case before the decision was made to the
I'm sort of like a comment on the
internal deliberations of the department
I will say that we have a 100,000
employees everyone has their role there
was a tremendous amount of discussion
within the department over the years in
part because of change in
administration's tremendous amount of
briefing a tremendous amount amount of
discussion I will say that the end of
the day for me general bar thoroughly
considered this case and made the
decision himself and that is I'll
address this and then I'll ask that you
direct any further questions of PIL will
Ansel investors can I know that it is
your best fashion limitation so the way
this comes into play in this case is
there are questions about exactly how
these different factors including the
chokehold and other things contributed
to mr. Gardner's death because of that
and because of the questions about what
exactly caused the death and what
combination of factors caused the death
we view this as the only case where the
government if it could prove the case at
all could prove beyond a reasonable
doubt perhaps that mr. Gardner suffered
serious bodily injury as a result of the
officers action that charge has a
five-year statute of limitations and
that's why an abundance of caution we
made sure that it was thoroughly
reviewed and the decision was made
before that five-year statute of
limitations was triggered okay thank you
all you can direct further questions to
the PIL and we'll address them the best
okay thank you for being good today